we're good what about the people who say
your hero for doing that no no good you
good I just want to get your egg Miss
Smith yeah we don't tell him I do that I
heard the crash and I heard someone
yelling so I get him a car come down i
call 9-1-1 and when i get here the truck
is over all other sides in flames
I'd climb it and I try to hit his own
this seat belt and he's hovered over and
see it bends on it and so I grab this
scissors for you cut the seat man but
it's on his neck so I said it's on my
neck so momma was if the flames come in
out I'll leave
I am but we cut it cut it off his neck
as the flames do come sailing so cabin I
lean back but I think what it did hit
his legs which made him extend you saw
the fighter and when he extends extends
out of the cabin pull him out and as we
pull him out within five seconds later
the truck goes up he didn't have to do a
thing and you know like I said earlier
that I think we all hope that we could
do something when the time is there but
the question is is do we do we act or do
we fear our own lives and he did not he
acted
and the good kind of acting not that
he's bad I love him